I'm thinking of Mike Flanigan and
Midnight Club how many times did you
audition for that or he just offered you
the part he just offered me the part see
I got the sides and the opening speech
of this character it was like one speech
and you kind of get to know Dr Georgina
Stanton basically um her son has died of
cancer and she's opened up a hospice for
kids with cancer who are terminal I'm
like literally on the one1 freeway
getting off at Los virgin is Canyon Road
and I decided to pull into the gas
station just to read the sides cuz
I had to do the audition the next
morning on my iPhone and I just wanted
to like go over it in my head while I'm
driving my long little windy road over
Malibu Canyon so I sit there and I'm
reading the sides and I just burst into
tears like cuz her story is not my exact
story but I lost my son to brain cancer
5 years ago this whole idea that she was
this woman who' lost her son and had
decided to open a hospice for kids with
cancer was something that really struck
a nerve in me